I'm but you're down 18 with the Raptors  shooting 64% you've cut it in half and  trail by only 9 at the break  Greg Gary and Caleta in the student  height the skill set Billy Owens at his  best yes and that is the end of the  phone quarter Kevin Durant has rated  with the astounding would he now has 38  points and the Warriors are down by just  as we  [Music]  [Applause]  the ramp  horses play  here's the ramp ten seconds goes to the  party  this is why we love basketball Kady  didn't even happen this is why we love  basketball Kady didn't even have the  ball in his hand correctly  he wasn't even sent everyone knew he was  going to shoot this ball that's why he  wants it at the end of day  [Applause]